양자 컴퓨팅은 실용의 시대에 들어섰어
이제 양자 컴퓨터를 실제 문제 해결에
사용하기 시작할 수 있다는 뜻이야. 고전 컴퓨터로는
풀기 아주 어려운 문제들도 포함해서
현재 시대의 공통된 특징은
문제가 풀리는 건데
최초로 양자 컴퓨터에서 풀리고
그다음에 사람들이 고전 컴퓨터로도
푸는 방법을 찾아내는 거야. 이런 고전
컴퓨팅과 양자 컴퓨팅이 서로를
한계까지 밀어붙이는 사이클은
몇 년간은 계속될 것 같아. 양자
컴퓨팅이 입증 가능한 우위를 가질 수 있는
문제 유형들이 있어
오류 감소나
사용 가능한 qubit 수 같은 영역에서 진전이 이루어진다면
또한 양자 컴퓨팅이
비교적 가까운 시일 내에
유용하게 쓰일 수 있는 응용 분야들도 있어
그 중 하나가 양자 머신러닝, 즉 QML이야
양자 머신러닝은
어떤 종류의 머신러닝 프로세스에든
양자 컴퓨팅을 적용하는 걸 말해. 물론
머신러닝의 종류는 많은데
특히 관심을 끄는 두 가지는
지도 학습이야. 레이블이 붙은 데이터셋으로
알고리즘을 훈련시키는 방식이고
비지도 학습도 있는데
알고리즘이 레이블 없는 샘플로부터
분포에 대해 학습하려고 하는 방식이야
또는 그 분포를 생성하는 함수를 학습하는 거야
비지도 알고리즘은 예를 들어
같은 분포에서 새로운 샘플을 생성하는 법이나
샘플들을 비슷한 특성을 가진
그룹으로 클러스터링하는 법을 학습할 수 있어
지도 학습과 비지도 학습 모두 흔히
데이터를 더 높은 차원의 공간에 임베딩하는 게 포함돼
그리고 고차원 공간에서 데이터를 조작하는 건
양자 컴퓨팅을 떠올리게 해야 해
왜 그런지 설명할게. 평면에서 데이터 포인트를
어떻게 분류할지 문제를 푼다고 상상해봐
여기 레이블된 훈련 데이터가 있을 때 원인지 십자인지
데이터를 선으로 명확하게 분리할 수 있을 때도 있어
저차원에서 평면이나 선으로
여기 보이듯이. 이 데이터 포인트들을 선 위와
선 아래로 분류하는 건
아무 문제 없어야 해
근데 이 분포를 봐봐
데이터 포인트를 분리하는 선이 보이지 않는 게 명백해
하지만 이 데이터에 대해 어떤
2차원에서 3차원으로의 매핑을 생각해볼 수 있어
그 매핑을 적용하고 나면 데이터가
이렇게 보이고 두 클래스를 분리하는 평면이 명확하게 보여
그 평면을 분류에
쓸 수 있어. 이 설명이 좀 단순해 보이면
맞아. 데이터 포인트를 그냥 아무 이유 없이
위로 올릴 수는 없어
매핑이 있어야 해
2D 분포에서 데이터 포인트를 효과적으로
분리해주는 매핑이 있어야
새로운 데이터 포인트를 분류하는 데 쓸 수 있어
이건 머신러닝
요약 강의에서 더 다룰 거야. 하지만 간단히 말하면
이 문제는
고차원 공간으로의 다양한 매핑을 시도해서
어떤 매핑이 서로 다른 클래스의
데이터 포인트를 가장 잘 분리하는지 찾는 걸로 볼 수 있어
고차원에서 데이터를 이렇게 조작하는 건
양자 컴퓨팅이 큰 영향을 미칠 수 있는
하나의 영역이야. 왜 그런지 이해하려면
고전 컴퓨팅과 양자 컴퓨팅의
차이점으로 돌아가보자
고전 컴퓨터가 비트 정보를 사용하는 것처럼
양자 컴퓨터는 qubit을 사용해
근데 같은 비트 수, 예를 들어 4비트라 하면
고전 컴퓨터는 가능한 상태 중
2의 4제곱, 즉 16개 중 하나를 취할 수 있어
양자 컴퓨터도 16개의 가능한 상태에 접근할 수 있지만
16개의 상태 모두의 중첩 상태로
동시에 존재할 수 있어
그리고 이 전체 중첩에 대해 연산을 수행할 수 있어
4 qubit에서는 이게 별로
대단하지 않아 보일 수도 있지만 2의 20제곱이나
양자 컴퓨터로 2의 127제곱
상태를 동시에 다루면 어떻게 될지 상상해봐
동시에. 고전 컴퓨팅과 양자 컴퓨팅 사이에는 다른 차이점들도 많아
이 주제에서 역할을 하게 될
차이점들이 다 있어
양자 상태는 복소 확률 진폭을 가져
양자 시스템의 조작은
유니터리 연산자로 이루어지고, 양자 컴퓨터는 고전 컴퓨터와
다른 종류의 노이즈에 영향을 받아
이런 차이점들은
양자 머신러닝 작업 전반에 걸쳐 나타날 거야
데이터 인코딩, 특징 매핑, 오류 완화 같은 분야에서
어떤 경우엔 고전 컴퓨터와 양자 컴퓨터의
이런 차이점 덕분에 완전히
새로운 알고리즘을 설계할 수 있어. 이제까지 아주 간략하게
두 개의 굉장히 복잡한 분야의 결합을
살펴봤는데 두 가지는 분명해졌길 바라
머신러닝은 흔히 문제를
아주 고차원에서 데이터를 조작해서 풀어
그리고 둘째로 양자 컴퓨터는 고차원에서
데이터를 조작하는 데 적합하고
고전 시스템과는 다른 방식으로 해
이걸 보면 왜
머신러닝이 유용한 양자 컴퓨팅을
적용하기에 유망한 분야인지 느낌이 올 거야